no I really love that show I know I like
big brother its back oh never watched
Big Brother brother
why what is that my guilty pleasure what
you're a big brother right you're just
watching pieces voyeurs well you have oh
don't you don't you do that or no no no
I had a big brother oh you had a big
brother yeah yeah when I was seven we
just went to dinner the other day away
so cuz your dad left right yeah oh not
it's nothing left I'd never knew my dad
you left that's why you don't know him
it's not like that I know what you're
saying
know what he did it's not in my life he
never was thanks for bringing that up
but go on don't touch him with your
hairy knuckles I'm here I thought we
felt we're but not to you by stamp stuff
do you know who your dad is no you don't
even know his name no I asked my mom
once yeah what she got a little you know
like me and so I got the name and I
wanted to know because I was like hey is
there diabetes in my family sure you
know that kind of [ __ ] you know horse or
diabetes oh my he's gonna turn them one
up you know my uncle but so anyway so
she told me his name yeah and then I
thought she was like do whatever you
want with that you know okay so then I
had the name and I was like okay I'll
see you about doing something about it
and then they're like a few weeks went
by I forgot the name mm-hmm and then it
told me that it really didn't matter
oh you didn't you weren't like I wasn't
like doing anything so when you're like
seven yeah
now your father leaves you you know to
go to his you know bachelor apartment
with no furniture you know I mean to
really show how much he hates his family
and kids that kind of thing would just
it would scar me oh yeah you know what I
mean he wasn't I'll just go back to you
that stunt his growth he was there when
you were born but he's had this pilot
these others my [ __ ] steaming pile of
[ __ ] like what is this due to your
relationships in your nobody it's like I
think first is if you were seven then
your father Lee yeah I think that's more
of a traumatic than like never knowing
it's like not have wanna because I watch
this show long-lost family right there
is a part of you that want to know or
even ask you that your mom's black right
no photographs at all not only their
photographs wow wow wow I'm gonna
probably I look very much like my mom
I'm uh I mean you know what a product of
an affair you know I mean like you know
alright yeah yeah so it's like this it
wasn't I don't even know all the facts
but what if what if he let me just say
something right no I did Bobby to me
stop you I already know see women have
their thing they all had they had their
secrets they have their reasons for
doing things right and I always when she
got upset about that I always thought
what if he wanted to be in my life but
my mom's like no you know I mean yeah
and she feels guilty about that I
already let it go I already like yeah
but what do I understand what you're
depriving him of though he's probably 95
it doesn't matter what if he needs you
in his life
well whatever yeah I know no no no
listen we're putting that guilt on me no
I'm just saying what if he's like I
didn't have kids of my own I should know
he did he did how do you know it was a
product of an affair I probably have
brothers and sisters out there someplace
I don't know what a weird feeling I mean
what do you ever know I I think about
like at this point at this age I'm just
kind of like what it is because I've
already missed the like where I see
people that have brothers and like when
I hear Bobby talking about his time with
Steve when you guys are growing up when
a time I hear that I go damn I'm never
gonna have that yeah I'm already an
adult I'm already have my quirks and
everything about me it's already done